[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today what's
going on today Jason so I have a excuse
me I have a u
a sorry I have a ketta that my daughter
wants to plan and um I don't know if you
guys are familiar but gett is pretty
much like a sweet 16 yeah y um we and
I'm I'm in
a bit of a pickle as to whether I could
or I
should um or if I could afford it or
should I do it how much is it gonna
cost
so estimated is I'm I'm estima between
10 and
15,000 wow and um you got an itemized
list on that no um another detail on
this is that I'm currently going through
a divorce with her mother and uh this is
kind of being planned by her and these
are their prices kind of or her prices
as far as what they've found I'm just
trying to see the problem is is that I
have just recently actually fully funded
my six-month emergency
fund but that takes into account any
support that I pay her um my
ex-spouse I don't know if I I'm
technically I can dip into
that but it's an emergency fund and this
is not an emergency yeah not only that
you can't afford it you're calling us
ask I the way that you're talking we
know you can't afford it am I right you
can't afford 10 to 15 they're expecting
you so they're planning like she's
planning it and then they're gonna
expect you to fot the whole
bill uh not foit the whole bill foot
half she was asking for uh at at the
beginning of all these talks was of half
of it half of 10 which was five but I
don't think that's realistic of what it
would cost I can if I save up until the
point of when this is supposed to happen
I could probably save about
4,000 okay but um I'm just whether I
should do this at this time in my life
like is
is uh Jason do you have any other do you
have any other debt
Jason no or any debt no debt okay but
you're fully funded fun how much do you
make a
year um over time's been good this year
so it's about at 120 120 okay so here's
my two things that I keep thinking as
you're talking um number one how we
Define an emergency to actually dip into
an emergency fund is when something is
unexpected so this doesn't really
qualify because we know that she's going
to be yeah is it is it is it 16 years
old or is it 15 it's 15 15 yeah okay so
we knew she was going to be turning 15
so it's not
unexpected uh is it urgent do I have to
do it like right now right now right now
yeah I guess that I guess urgent would
somewhat qualify and because there's a
date there and is it necessary right so
these are the two things so honestly
this whole thing it does not check off
all those boxes for me so no it's
technically not an
emergency um so that's that's one part
of the discussion the second part is
that that you could bring together some
money right and let's just say and
pretend that it is 10,000 they want to
do five you could save four could you
take a th000 out of the emergency fund
to to get to the five sure like you
could right I mean it's not the end of
the world but my my biggest problem with
all of that though Jason is that just
like weddings just like another party
just like vacations anything if you
don't keep a strict budget and have a
limit to what you're going to spend it
gets expensive more expensive I mean a
house even when you build a house same
thing like the line continues to move so
Jason if you decide to do this and to
save the 4,000 for her which I think
think would be great right like I don't
think that's a necessarily a bad thing
okay Ken's not that happy about it if
you do it though there has to be very
clear communication and and boundaries
with your future ex-wife to say and and
your daughter I would bring her in on it
and say guys this is the this is what's
going on here's what I will have for you
this is it this is all I can do in good
conscience and in good faith at where I
am in life this is what I
have work with that right and you set
the tone you set the amount on what you
can do Jason because if you tell them
sure I'll do half it's going to go from
10 to 15 to 20 and there's going to be
No Boundaries so you have to set that
bound okay Ken's dying over here I'm
dying I'm dying I agree with everything
Rachel said I just want to say this I'm
gonna try I'm gonna I'm going to answer
this if as if I was in your shoes and I
don't I don't know if there's any
special features to this party so I'm
completely ignorant uh but if my
daughter Josie who by the way turns 15
tomorrow uh if she came to me and said I
want a big party and I've got a budget I
think it's going to be 10 I would ask
for an itemized list there's no way I'm
even GNA give four five six without
seeing where what are the speci where is
the where in the world is 10 grand going
for a party for a bunch of 15y olds so
I'm starting there um and and so I would
say that everything Rachel said is
absolutely right you give your number
after they give you numbers you don't
just get well it's going to be 10 maybe
12 maybe 15 you give half and and you
you you have to ask for specifics and
have a real conversation with your
daughter and you're in a very tough
situation now with the divorce and now
she's got two don't let guilt and don't
let the guilt right over that J say baby
here's the deal okay give me your budget
what do you want for your party let's
just walk through it let's teach her
this is a teaching moment to go yeah I'd
like to drive a
Lamborghini but but I can't and so I
know you want a $10,000 party but guess
what me and Mom can't do a $10,000 party
but we can make it an amazing party and
this is how much money I can give
towards an amazing party I think that's
the conversation well it's not I think
that's exactly how I would talk it over
with my daughter Josie I'd get her wish
list get real numbers and then how can I
meet her expectations in a much more
budget conscious way I think that's
where you start yeah it takes the
pressure off because now you're dealing
in reality and and then you go look babe
this is what I can do yeah and this
stuff Jason and I know it's such a
cultural part right can see like I know
that it is and and I know like you know
um and we I remember we had a guy call
um I think it from India in the wedding
that he wanted to spend like half a
million dollars right so like I I
totally am aware that there are certain
things culturally that the expectation
is really big but culture should never
out rule common sense but that's it too
so I'm like it's and you could say about
the American culture right weddings or
whatever like you could plug in other
things so so you do have to there's
going to be multiple areas Jason within
you that you're going to have to be like
this oh this is not doesn't feel right
it's not what I wanted but part of being
a grown-up to Jason is looking at the
numbers what Ken's saying and it's like
here's just here's the reality here's
the reality of what we have and what we
can or what I have and what I can do um
and so coming back to you Jason you have
a real number in your head that you feel
like I can't afford you feel like a guy
who in control of his money situation
you sound really stable what's the
number that you go if I set it on fire
for my daughter it wouldn't bother me
wouldn't give me a MAO moment what is
that
number well right now the the big thing
that is heavy on me is that I haven't
even gotten into my investing portion of
my life for the future I get that but
you didn't answer my question what's the
number that you if you know I can give
this money to my daughter and I'm not
going to lose sleep over it
um as of now I would say maybe for
something like this 3,000 okay then then
now we've got a starting number I'm
trying to coach you through this
practically you got a number where you
go yeah I know you don't want to spend
any money because you think you're
behind you're not you're going to be
fine on your investing you got to
weather this divorce you got to figure
out what the payments are going to be
and all that you're going to restart
okay but you're okay but if the number's
3,000 when you go that's my baby girl
she say I can give her three grand then
let's start with that then go get the
itemized list and let's see if we can
you know get closer to it that that's
what I'm trying to do is get you to a
point where you don't let guilt run the
day and make a bad financial decision
and I think the 3,000 is a common sense
number would you
agree I would say so yeah all right and
your ex-wife's not gonna like it yeah so
prep for that and your daughter may not
like it she don't like you right now
anyway so we're not losing that deal I
mean I'm not trying sens I'm just
keeping it real what are you going to
do make or not want to be married to you
more I mean we've already crossed that
bridge so you got to stick to your guns
man and uh get the item yeah Jason
you're a good man you're going to be
fine it's going to be a great party yes
create your free every dooll budget
today the simplest way to budget for
your life